okay I'm live I'm on Ches comm the title
are not titled it's just the Kings arena
cache tournament it's starting in about
four minutes and currently I'm just
watching the the u.s. championship
schemes they started about an hour ago
openings are reaching completion players
are entering the middle games so I won't
be following the games for the next two
hours next two hours will fully be
devoted to the arena Kings tournament
but we'll try and stay entertained for
now this is a match of the day between a
wonder and Fabiano honestly I'm rooting
for a wonder just because he's underdog
I played him for the first time in the
tournament back when he was 6 years old
and he was already rated like 1800 and
we played in st. Louis it was actually
part of the Thanksgiving Open where was
run by the st. Louis chess club and we
had like a four-hour game which I
eventually won but then he beat me many
many times over the years and now he's
playing us championship against a big
dog they have a relatively quiet opening
we go back here some kind of early
Bishop b5 Sicilian I know this has been
trendy I know Fabiano has played this
for both sides so I assume both players
were somewhat well prepared and I think
a wonder is just happy being solid and
there's really no reason to go crazy
I mean I'm sure he'll be very happy with
a draw in round 1 against the top seed
so it seems like he's playing somewhat
more controlled than than usual because
he is a pretty aggressive player now I'm
wondering if the time stamps are
actually correct because I wonder has an
hour and 17 minutes and he's
significantly up on time and I know one
of his biggest weaknesses having played
them not too long ago is time management
and just not not moving quickly enough
early on in the game but it seems like
he's managing his time well so if
there's anyone in the chat let me know
if things look ok the chat seems pretty
quiet right now let me refresh
everything tournament starts in two
minutes I'm sure there's other people
streaming maybe everyone's just watching
the u.s. championship there's no reason
to watch me play on chess calm right now
I shouldn't say that but sort of the
truth okay it seems to be live let me
check the audio okay audios looking good
cool it's gonna be a very small crowd
today I'm thinking PCM twitch saying it
looks ok that's good yesterday I
streamed and my microphone wasn't
plugged in for most of it and no one
told me and the audio was just bad but
now I see the microphones plugged in it
should be working
getting some notification I was so
tweeted I don't usually tweet to promote
my streams but I tweeted about this
stream just to try and get some some
more viewers so it's my phone going off
ooh someone retweeted Thank You Kristin
for retweeting me whoever you are on
Twitter
ok tournaments just about starting any
switch windows here ooh John Ludwig
hammer is playing interesting I saw Amon
hamilton was playing too but now I don't
see him and I'm sorry like I've I would
share the standing or the cross table
thing but it's too complicated to
incorporate because it's such a small
window and a lot of the names are cut
off but here we go round 1 let's play
quick every second counts I think the
strategy is to play as many games as
possible
and obviously win as many games as
possible and the play of Budapest
one of my pet lines for blitz we'll see
how well prepare he is Knight c3 we can
play Knight to Knight c6 here and then
it taken Queenie side
and we're following something in line
I'm expecting Queen D 5.83
then he has Queen d2 or Roxy 1 these are
the two main moves if rook c1 I have to
play F 6
but if Queen d2 I can play Queen a5 and
it's a good sign he's thinking here so
I'm still in prep Queen d2 okay now
black is guaranteed to win this pawn I
think after a night 85 and I'll admit
that I'm sort of out of prep but the
position should be somewhat easy for
black to play we can trade on e5 if he
wants but now he's left with these
double pawns and black won the pawn back
so I I like the position here it's kind
of a feel good position I'm ready to
Castle next move he might play Queen e3
to apply some pressure but I always have
moves like d6 Queen e3 looks awkward for
him I mean maybe he'll try and justify
it somehow but I mean ok if he plays c5
I'm happy just a castle also a2 is
hanging which maybe I can consider
taking next move but there's issues for
white because he's not developed his
Queens on e3 blocking is econ pawn on c4
opponent c3 are weak there's a lot of
issues I'm just ready to castle like
develop with tempo this is nice okay
let's not trade Queens
rook b5 I forgot about that move maybe I
underestimated my position but I can
take on a - things are about to get
spicy because you can take on e5 I have
to play Bishop e6 it's a question of
which king is less safe this is okay I
mean if he takes on e6 there's no
Perpetual my king can run to safety
somehow if he doesn't take any six it
gives me time to castle f4 he wants to
play f5 but now I can just Castle
queenside castling queenside hello 2x
villager or Castle kingside I don't know
indecisive Castle queenside get the rope
to the D file right away now c4 is
hanging a sevens defended by my queen
okay he plays g3 so his Kings gonna hide
on f2 I can take on c4 it's gonna be a
sharp position
Queen B one check does that do anything
[Music]
probably not
[Music]
we have some idea I'll take on sea for a
fish up cheats you do I have work t1
rook to e1 King take t1 Queen B one King
D to reptilians and this works rip t1
King Teti one queen bee one Queen c1
rock t8o his Bishop d5 take ah maybe it
doesn't work
Bishop d5 maybe I just rook lift this is
complex
these sevens of targets she don't know
what's going on maybe Queen c2 preparing
work t1 and that hangs a7 and always
play King V aids I'll drop the bishop
back to a6 it's not preferable I'm gonna
do it though cuz I am up a pawn oh he
can castle I forgot he to Castle he
doesn't Castle rook t2 maybe no Ricky
Yates is getting initiative well I
forgot there's no increment - oh my gosh
okay I have to play quick completely
forgot there's no increments Queen c4 I
got to simplify f6 was a bad move that's
strong or is it let's do this maybe I
can take on e2
Wow getting crushed here maybe some hope
it's not likely chess where I can like
survive with seven seconds left
I'll start pre moving oh my gosh oh
that's really unfortunate cuz I have a
good position I've I forgot about time
that's not a good starts but the
tournament keeps going I'm gonna forget
about that game definitely an
interesting position to analyze it just
got real very very sharp I think I just
underestimated his play 95 okay we're
going into this line um do I play d5 i
think ii v RC v g5 is like the name move
i'll admit i don't know too much theory
here especially after Knight c3 maybe
Bishop e6 let's defend the pawn and then
put the Queen on h5 is he gonna take on
c7 f3 okay now he can't take on c7
because Queen eight or Queen c5
hmm play queen c5 immediately now I'm
gonna play queen c5 defend all the pawns
and then repeat hello Connor jr. thanks
for watching
maybe you look here this Queens almost
trapped never mind
Bishop f5 e for mmm let's double up on
the B file I want to bring the knight to
some better square let's play a 5
maybe Queen b6 complying more pressure
to the pawn maybe I have ideas of like
97 to c5 to d3 I'll probably try and
execute that very soon it's 206 players
in this tournament I'm tied for last
place but it's still early 9 minutes had
passed I'm playing the number
oh he's number 9 seed interesting why
was he gonna play rook d1 because I back
rank matrix maybe if he plays rook baby
while I play h6 and he can't take on d7
because rook take b2 infant flash chess
yes this is a tournament it's a cash
tournament for streamers I think Jessica
calm has this like every week I guess
you could call it a mini tournament it's
not as like prominent as title Tuesday
but the tracks allow players is over 200
players playing currently last week I
played and I won like them the Twitter
poll for the most popular streamer so I
won some some cash so I'm trying to
repeat this week I'm trying to actually
place at least like top 5 top 10 this
week if possible I think I'd have to
take this night and then I have to take
with pawn rook take I can take on b2
right tick-tick-tick
and he has some some capture in the end
maybe this yeah Knight on d3 should be a
good plan or even 96 very solid square
for the Knights
hello Tom Haas 1 hello - boo chianti
Bishop e3 I completely forgot about but
I think I can now take on b2
Oh No Brooke take me to work take me to
Queen take me to theirs rook ta then the
end that hurts
what do I do here Queen f6 maybe Queen
f6 I don't know I'm playing on new
tuition I might have to like cheaply
flag this guy gonna have sex I'm still
threatening taking on b2 I think he can
get away with taking on c5 though
there's a big c5 roped a p2 wrote a p2
or take me to there's work to you and
it's annoying wreck t8 move but he's
thinking that's good so even if he finds
it he'll probably hopefully flag I don't
know if I even want to play take me to
here because he sees a line but maybe
it's the best line I don't know let's
play it
rook d8 yeah now h5 and I'm gonna try
and infiltrate with my queen and then
flag him it's dirty but that's the
nature of know increments at 6 always
play f6 maybe check let's start with
King h7 make him think I'm up 10 seconds
now I can check and then go in for the
kill
I'm trying to meet him is oh I forgot
about that move no he has at least a
draw ouch
wait don't meet me I should see 5 is
scary oh my gosh this is bad this is
really bad
don't make me no he made it me oh that's
such a bad start
mm okay no one to blame but myself that
game okay now I'm playing someone lower
rated I can't piss er right there's no
way to berserk on chess calm I'm gonna
play another Budapest this time
let's uh
okay let's be aggressive getting
continually getting notifications oh
I've had good position so far - based on
the openings there's any tricks work
bishop takeoff - doesn't really work
maybe e4 though II four might work
because if he takes on e4 I take back
with Knight and if he moves this Knight
then I can take on f2 okay I might
actually be winning material here yeah I
think he's in trouble
oh he could take on f6 oh I completely
forgot about that but at least I uh I'm
not losing a pawn I have bishop before
check if he takes on e4 and this could
be still be pretty strong because Knight
d2 Queen take b2
you see is rookie one but I like this
position I'm castled is king sides not
developed a rugby one do I have to trade
not right away if he plays rook b3 or
queen me through now I have to trade or
wait a minute I could take the Queen to
let's just take the Queen then the
bishop will come back I have the bishop
pair maybe Bishop outside
well his rook might be getting trapped
actually it might not be but his rook
has to be careful for example like rook
b2 here okay that just loses a pawn and
let's do this
there is pressure against the King
Bishop d3 almost winning a peaceful play
Knight e4 how do I win the piece maybe I
just develop and he's just stuck or I
play this move wait now let's play c5 I
like c5 because I attack the knight if
you take sides continue to attack the
knight and if the Knights attacks and
has to move then the bishop will be
hanging so if he takes on c6 here I just
take on e2 and this is crushing I just
wanna hold his pieces I'm just meeting
him rookies mates
random question from infinite infinite
flash chess is there a way to get a safe
stable advantage against Kings Indian I
can recommend some lines but I can't
recommend them now because I'm a bit
busy playing this tournament I'll do
I'll do another like Q&A stream did this
guy really disconnect you serious
remember offline can I just end the game
its mate next move which is chest like
I'll not have the this feature
I'll meet us if if the point runs away
in like a position where its mate then
you can just claim victory that's a bit
annoying but ok just wasted a little bit
of time there next game communism chess
ok now I'm playing Gregory let's be
aggressive it's trying to get a streak I
lost the first few games I was not a
great Street to start with I'm gonna
play some kind of Grand Prix attack if
he lets me play this Bishop b5 long yeah
I've I've played this many times in
blitz very fine opening a six play d3 d5
I don't think I can do the same line do
I do against d5
taketake I have to play Bishop b3 I
guess it seems like he might have some
prep here or maybe it's just a normal
position now
d4 ambitious let's do this
he has two bishops but it's a somewhat
stable position maybe I'll play Knight
f4 try and use a d5 square another for
queen up three I mean he might play b5
Bishop d7 I'm not sure if I want to play
Knight d5 what to do okay I'll play
Knight e5 anyway try and make this work
f5 he's playing well f5 scary move my
five is very very scary
maybe Bishop f4 though I can just
neutralize everything I mean we could
trade rook e8 okay everything's still
defended maybe I'll put my queen back
here at some point I might have to play
c4 I give Bishop c6 I can take and play
c4 Bishop b5 while he's playing very
very strongly I'm just losing an
exchange
can i play c4 taketake no I didn't mean
to play Queen c3 what do what was that
wait what okay I resign
I mean okay the position was worse
anyway but I don't know how I even now
slipped that is there is there a
click-click maybe I clicked clicked oh
that's why as our way to disable that
because I remember I've done those mouse
lips a lot on me chess where yeah you
don't even realize that like you clicked
clicked the thing how such a bad start
okay I'm playing Creek or who I know is
also streaming and I play them twice in
the last event and I be
both times and then I beat him in the
Twitter poll too so I'm I'm pretty much
dominating this guy and all facets of
life and I think I played the London
last time oh he's playing this line I
think I can take I can get away of
taking maybe it's a bit risky but okay
we'll see what happens it's why Bishop
b5 gonna be super greedy and hang on to
this one
or this pawn on c5 I remember the last
couple of times I played him you is just
very slow but maybe now he's faster okay
he's attacking both pawns can I hold on
to both maybe take and take and play
Knight d4 that's looking kind of messy
97 good move what to do
take Knight e4 e5 take looks messy but
yeah that's too messy Oh what to do
I'm the castle I'm gonna make him think
I took way too long there and he doesn't
even think in that position okay it's
just probably slightly worse for whites
but at least I have development I just
have to stop him from expanding in the
center I take I guess I take his I have
less space will trade rough more stuff
if he lets me I would love to make the a
file half open that's a decent move
let's trade oh I'm allowing a 5 Bishop
h2 fine maybe I should have considered
taking on e4 there
okay he doesn't want to trade so he's
playing principal chess
maybe I'll go for c4 it's like we need
to going for a c4 ah a 4 a 4 is not the
move I want to play let's play Knight c5
try and reinforce at night maybe I can't
reinforce the night but I'll play 9 a4
and then maybe play b3 play a bit slowly
here
the bishop a6 is going to come at some
point still going to try and play c4
it's hard for him to stop and my knight
is actually pretty solid on e4 I'm just
trying to play quickly I keep up the
tempo so I mess up there c4 is defended
I think I Bishop on h2 is not that
impressive though but neither is this
Bishop on g7 and the double pre moving
is weird
I guess it's sufficient though okay so
he still has two bishops I gotta figure
out how to improve my terrible bishop I
could play c5 maybe
yeah c5 is interesting and allows Bishop
b5 though I don't know I'm gonna go for
this long planet Bishop do you want two
three four I don't see what else to do
he's attacking the pawn let's defend it
with the Queen I got to move much faster
well I hung a rook wait that wasn't even
a mouse if I just forgot my rook was
hanging
nope I didn't mean to offer JA I meant
to resign oh well the bad start I don't
even want to see the standings I've only
won one game but there's still 95
minutes left if I can get a streak maybe
good things will happen such low quality
chess I've fallen way below 2400 okay we
have some alop in Sicilian I am titled
I'm not playing like a title player
though 95 what does 95 take take take
take
let's play Bishop d7 I'm happy trading
minor pieces because he has an IQ p I'm
not good with the tactics today but I'm
good with a positional chess wait did
you say title they're tilted oh you are
tilted yeah uh-huh completely misread
that I'll trade more maybe I should take
with Knights avoid him taking on d5
mmm tickle him a little bit Bishop f4
put the rook on the C file go for d5
it's just an easier position to play for
black I don't want to trade nights
because I don't want this lots of color
Bishop scenario and I c5 is a bit
annoying I can do that
there better not be tactics here for
white mmm
a5 so if I take he takes on b7 I take on
you one he takes I take the rook he
takes on do you type Laver up there
looks dry actually I have Queen before
though
- wait position get very tactical very
quickly let's play h6 Oh deep was G for
hanging before may have been hanging his
queens died down to eat one where my
tactics 906 maybe looks playable yes to
play Queenie - and then I can take on d4
and he can take on b7 my tactics are not
sharp today but I mean I think this is
working
actually if he takes on b7 I take on c2
his Queens overworked also I'm
threatening c5 and the knight is sort of
pin to the rook maybe he has 93 but then
I still take on c2 Wow ok I move I
didn't consider but this just fails to
rotate c2 and then Queen taking you
watch okay next game try and start a
streak I still don't know how the
streaks work I don't think they really
explained the point system let's play a
London this game I was avoiding taking
the d4 pawn because I forgot the d4 pawn
was hanging in some lines oh this guy
knows what he's doing this was kind of
my pet line it's still not a bad
variation I mean White has two bishops
black will get some center he's playing
pretty quickly seems confident
okay he wants to play e5 let's go for a
four go for some positional play maybe a
five what to do here
I'll put the Queen on h4 also I'm now
stopping me five but this looks pleasant
because now my knight can come in to e5
see for maybe c4 f6 take on d5 looks
fine this is where the two bishops kind
of flourish is I mean when the position
opens up the bishops become happy they
work together and blacks kind of tied
down here I just want to take on d5 next
and black will have an IQ P and this
night is so bad and he ate so he wants
to trade Queens which I think I'm okay
with I mean I could also just take here
let's take your first he takes my queen
I'll win the b6 pawn yeah this is nice I
mean if I can win a few games all
hopefully alleviate the tilts you know
I'm throwing Bishop c5 put the bishop on
d4 I guess just up upon great Bishop
let's play this move first preventing
any 92 shenanigans may be preparing f3
let's play top three because now if
ninety six I had Bishop e5 and where
else does might go if 906 I just take it
now I'm attacking the knight in the pond
the night spins of the rook this is
pretty much game over with another pawn
we can trade I'll put the bishop on c3
put the rook on the D file and he's not
resigning so I wouldn't resign this
position either is okay b2 is under
pressure but he's not actually
threatening to take it how do I make
progress d7 just play H for improving
move maybe I'll play rook b1 and b3 or
even before I forgot about before before
looks like a nice move you might play a
5 here but we'll see okay before
throwing the check if he plays King g6
maybe I made him somehow
now I can just advance
winning the night's um I mean I can give
up the bishop if necessary I mean I can
just take all those pawns maybe I should
have found a quicker way to win this but
this is good enough going for the kill
okay next game is that a two-point
streak I have no idea what place I'm in
I think it says I have seven points
let's play e5 this game will see what
line II plays Italian I'm okay playing
this d4 I think I take is it going to be
like a Mac slaying attack Knight g5 I
was looking at this other day what's the
move here 9h 695 is a mistake nine each
six is the best move and then he does
these tactics and then we trade I'm King
f8 I guess or no g6 yeah g6 and then d6
Oh Queen d5 I guess is a decent
Intermezzo but I think this is okay I
don't think I formally studied this but
I looked it up for a student once Bishop
g5 okay we can trade Queens but here's
Bishop h6 and some lines maybe Queen e5
I'm happy with this Queen trade his
pawns are equal
I'll take with pawn
it's annoying I have no idea what place
I'm in I guess I would have to scroll
down in the standings
and I'm really confused why why does it
say join I know I'm in the tournament
but there's a big join button right next
to the thing if anyone else is like
monitoring the tournament on live chess
you can tell me what place this is in or
what place I'm in that would be nice
okay let's play c5 I mean he might play
c3 ok 93 is gonna hit with hit him with
tempo uh he's attacking me this is not
dangerous let's do this first I have a
lot of tempo moves here I've got Bishop
g4 I'd be 593 it's just a matter of
which moved to play in order
maybe 93 now 93 is terrible because he
takes him takes on d6 mm-hmm I'm gonna
lose the D pawn that's fine I can win a
four but I want to open up files mmm
Bishop g4 and then Roky eights I should
not take too much time here but it's an
interesting moment let's do this Bishop
f5 and then I'll probably bring the
knight to e3 because 93 its rook e1 I
can take on g2 rook t2
it's actually hard to remove let's play
a five idea of rook a six I didn't see
what what else to do their work a six
might not be a bad plan we might we
might get some offs of color Bishop
ending if he takes on e3 and I take on
d6 but I'm okay with that because my
queen side majority is kind of nice
already have a nice face advantage and I
might get the the e-file as well okay
going for this I'm okay trading off one
pair of Brooks I don't want to trade off
both pairs of rooks let's play Bishop e4
why not I have the time advantage this
should be a pretty routine win
get the D file for the rook do I take
care do I push I can take I'll take on
c5 I play rookie I'm threatening me in
one and he oh he didn't miss it
yeah I was in check ooh surviving here
sorted okay we can trade not sure what's
going on in this position I'm gonna try
and set up some kind of mates which
won't work but I'll I'll just flag him
I'm very bad at like pre moving on like
this just feels different okay there we
go okay next game is that three in a row
I think that's three in a row I have 11
points
it looks like the leader has 37 points
I'm not catching up to that unless the
streaks work in some unusual way he's
playing in Kings Indian setup I think
the thematic move okay never mind
we're transposing into open Sicilian
I'll go for an early h5 push like right
now at some point I'll play ya a6 go for
Knight g4 so the pleasant line to play
do I have Bishop c5 already played
Bishop c5 yeah I think he missed Queen
take g3 this is over right I'm
threatening mates it's a nice little
trick
checkmate okay I need more games like
that just quick wins I see em I'm in
28th place
okay I'm playing I think this guy also
streams doubt weed says something from
Czech Republic I assume from Poland
okay we have a London play the line I
always play okay this is one of the most
topical lines well play Bishop e5
secondary move it's a choice of Magnus
Carlsen he takes on g3 this is probably
one of the best responses
it's Queenie for the move and Queen a
force a move here I have a feeling he
might know what he's doing
oh can you take on b2 okay he didn't
consider it that might have been
dangerous but maybe I had rook to be one
sometimes white can make use of the H
file okay well now I can't even castle
so I better make use of the H file let's
play 95 focus on the center
it's a little bit uncomfortable because
Rick situ might be coming
so if 93 rook c2 I can bring the knight
to f3 what to do maybe queen bee three
ideas of a4 hello Pak wash good to see
you
I'm sorry I've I haven't been able to
interact with the chat too much because
I'm busy playing games there is money on
the line I just play for here the pawns
pinned but I am threatening Queen take
me five
maybe he'll retreat with a bishop bishop
c6 but that seems sad my bishop sees too
excited at the very least head queen d3
yes that okay but now all of my problems
are solved he has to take with pawn I
don't know why he's thinking and now I
might just go for this g4 g5 push he
plays g6 it's normal still play g4 he
gives a check do this
maybe I'll play g3 in kingi - oh he
wants to play at six little but f6 I can
just take on u6 mm-hmm he's focusing on
the queenside I just want to focus on
the kingside or just in the center now
there's ideas of like 97 9.6 okay he
wants to trade Queens that's probably a
good decision for him I can't avoid it
let's throw in g5 maybe I still have
some mating attack Knight g4 906 he
still has to be careful or 97 906 yeah I
play with tempo I have the time
advantage that's nice
so here I can take on pissant I'm taking
it on pass once the best move I also
have 906 m n g4 I'm gonna do that
because I think it keeps initiative
there's so much pressure now I'm
probably still winning upon so you can't
take on g4 rook age sevens mate I'm
expecting or catch a hear that so he's
gonna sack he sacks mmm this key me to
Playa move
yeah the rooks are pretty dominant
trying to go for some kind of mating
nets not yet meet this is good enough
okay next game I think I moved up to 26
place I've I have a streak of five does
that mean five in a row maybe well let's
play another London let's do this stuff
good quote from infinite flash chess I'm
gonna have to look at that when I get
the chance
okay we have the same line that I just
played we're gonna play Bishop b5 again
the same exact opening 97 okay this is a
move I look forward to 9f 5 95 is
probably the best move but maybe 95 here
go for some King side attack is that the
first follow of the day thank you the
chest death cult appreciate the follow
what's going on here efore take take
take tick tick tick tick
no let's just play you for no time to
calculate type of move that will
hopefully make him think it's weird to
open up the center when I'm castled in
my opponent or when I'm not castle that
my opponent is castled but there's
targets this Bishop this rook this h7
pawn I just want to open up some more
lines
and I guess one key point is if he takes
on e4 I take with bishop he plays rook
there's knight c6 in the end assistance
is this actually gonna happen oh no he
oh he's sacking the rook do I want to
take it tick tick
queen up three maybe looks fine ooh
there should be seven I forgot about
that move but I'm still up the exchange
just have to be careful maybe queen g4
if the G file opens maybe I get some
mating attack bishop take G to rip t1
this is interesting because now that f5
is so solid though well what's going on
okay things are getting very very
complicated ninety seven maybe
I have no idea what's going on Bishop f4
is a candidate move allowing Queenie for
though it's not good when I take f7 what
to do here f3 f3 is interesting let's
play f3 it's getting very complex I'm
just dropped blocking the defense of the
Queen to the bishop I want to play
rotate g2 next 93 I think I can just
take on d4 if he takes on e5 I take back
on e5 that might be the critical line
but then there's some deep deep lines
here there's a big e5 Bishop to e5 can I
take bishop take out three Queen take g7
is that me wait Queen take g7 9 hg 7
rook to g7 King h8 rook f7 King g8 rip
g7 King h8 rook GE 6 rook f6 I mates is
this real life this is like tactics
trainer I think this is mates
this better be means it's one of these
classic windmill positions this is nice
I was sensing some lion like that but ok
that's nice
blazing hard for you with the cheer one
bit
thanks so much oh hello to me and
infinite flash chess yeah ok I'm keeping
the streak oh so it says my place now
that's weird
I wasn't saying my place before I'm 19th
place I have a streak of six games I
have 23 points
okay c5 and he's thinking complicated
position we'll have a time on of Knight
takes c6 not a theoretical line actually
there's some maybe some theory to this
this should be four I think Bishop
before some move c2 so e5 yeah there's
definitely theory to this I forget what
I'm supposed to take on c3 or if I'm
supposed to take on c3 I could play deef
now d5 doesn't look right maybe a five
she don't know what to do here my play
Bishop c5 slowing down any f4 idea
sometimes I can put the bishop on d4
let's play five easy move that's some
point he might play 9a for that he's
going for other plans now I can play d6
complete developments there should be
five might be annoying but deal with it
if it happens let's play h6 kick the
bishop once maybe g5 Bishop e3 let's
play Bishop t4 if the pawn gets to d4 is
Knight doesn't have a great place to go
hmm is going through this display repeat
another easy move rook e8 will be
another easy move I was rook be it I'm
preventing him from playing Knight d2
and you can't really play B 3 or B 4 so
he plays Queen c2 so next movie wants to
play Knight d2 ok I'll just do this I'll
play C 5 very soon and then my Bishop is
happier than his bishop because my pawns
aren't on dark spheres his centered
pawns are on light squares and I'll
develop somewhat quickly maybe a 4 at
some points a force probably not
necessary okay he plays repeat one clear
intentions let's find out H five ideas
of attacking hello to our X ah wait a
minute before I guess that's a move
take take wait take take take I can win
upon at the cost of bad clown structure
what to do maybe just queen here or
maybe I take and then I play Queen there
now he has to worry about Queen III also
has to worry about 9 F 4 and like all
these attacking moves
okay this is somewhat enjoyable now
that's fine defending g2 covering III
still play this now as Queen is tied
down maybe I can use some kind of
tactics may be also bishop wait 9h 3 9 H
3 I think wins a piece because I have
made f2 in the end the more chess I play
the sharper tactics or the the sharper
with tactics I be calm okay next game
playing some other guy I moved up to
14th place I have a streak of seven
games on the same line people are just
repeating the same lines today can i
play Bishop a6 here that's an
interesting move but let's be normal
okay different than masking as White's
pawn is not on c4 play Bishop g7 maybe
g6 mmm he's playing very aggressively
play c5 maybe maybe Queen b6 first wait
a minute he wants to play Bishop g7 I
don't think I'm scared of that let's
play Queen b6 more bits from from
blazing heart appreciate it I take on e5
and play Bishop at 6
probably not I play f5 probably not but
maybe
okay chess is complicated I will play
Bishop a6 because that Bishop was doing
nothing this Bishop is doing sort of
something on d3 and maybe I'll Castle
queenside at some point okay he does
that we could trade Queens let's trade
everything and then in the end maybe his
pawn is weak on e5
d4 is a threat also a Bishop takes c3 is
a threat you have to play Bishop d2 I
think yeah what did you just play
quickly I don't think I have a huge
advantage here but I have a nice
position
Bishop d4 looks like it's right now that
just winds up on or it does it rook c1
rook c8 I guess just to play bishop at
four mmm Bishop c3 take take let's do
this interesting somehow this got
passive I still don't mind the position
a fives with right now also be miss
Bishop g5 that's nice okay still have to
prove I still have to convert the
exchange let's play this now a5 is hard
to stop
you might play king f2 and a5 Bishop t6
or that's if he plays before I'll play a
5 well I can't take Casillas Bishop c7
mmm let's do this slowly but surely have
the time advantage now trying to keep
the streak
let's take put the knight on c4 there's
just over an hour left so about halfway
through what to do
maybe f6 or maybe h6 g5 ideas I want to
create some open files on this side
okay I'm fine with this put their work
on a six and bring the other wrote f7
let's go for g5 if at 500 work f7 f6
no I was asking for but it should be
okay
Kisatchie look sure looks kind of risky
f7 I think it's still objectively better
for black so I work out fate coming I'm
in this or maybe this yeah and I'm about
to Fagin
okay next game
do I miss a chance to take a pawn on e5
I may have huh who knows g6 let's play a
perk modern typing d6 let's play h4 the
early pawn thrust in Bishop g5 a4 why
not Bishop c4 okay
maybe f3 preventing any g4 exploits
almost trapping is my king each 7 is
forced maybe some day I'll try and put
my night on g5 but that could take a
while ee 5 take take we could trade hmm
I'm okay with this can play a queen this
mobile game because I'm fully developed
and if he takes on d2 I'll control the D
file
okay Queenie eights so he's avoiding the
Queen trade maybe 9f2
anything better
Bishop d5 maybe let's try Bishop g5 you
might play c6 in my play Bishop b3 and
then b6 is attacked now I can play a
five okay I'll take with rook Bishop c6
this looks pretty crushing that Knights
pinned and attacked three times okay
next game that was nice was a 2300 rated
player I broke 2,400 again it's a second
day in a row breaking 2,400 I have a
streak of nine games I just broke the
top 10 I had a very slow start
I'm trying to come back d5 okay we'll
have a qgd Bishop e7 this is my pet line
with a6 which okay he's just not really
paying attention to nuances I'm still in
prep
I think c5 better be prep yeah I think
c5 a fine move and then 97 Queen b6 I
guess the development is pretty natural
for luck like rook da rook c8 9 f8 Nagi
6 mm-hmm take with Knights
heading to 2,500 got that far away from
that but we'll see Queen c2 what is he
doing he wants to meet me Bishop b4 not
necessary let's just do this take with
rook Queen is short on squares Queen b3
Bishop e5 I can also take on f3 if I
want at some point wait he has he has
problems here Knight c3 b4 Queen b3
Bishop d5 I will see where his queen is
hiding 93 oh he wants to play d4 Knight
a for take take mmm
interesting interesting
take take I wouldn't be - maybe that's a
pawn there's my work getting trapped ooh
[Music]
rookie - that actually looks very risky
oh that was not intended take take I
have two bishops hmm take take never
gets trapped
maybe I play that position let's try
that if I can take on that three well I
forgot about rook c7 but I can take on
that three anyway I think 984 was a key
move there because now I'm just up upon
he's debating which Bishop to take okay
Bishop d6 I guess oh wait d6 sure why
not if he ever tries rip to you when I
officiate a gage - so he wants to win
the pawn back it's logical maybe h5
let's play h5 no that doesn't do
anything let's play g5 for others
bishops on beat one now
I'm taking too much time
what do I do here I've to rescue my rook
because might see force coming this is
gonna be a fight I'm expecting night c4
rope d5 as he for hurt me before might
be very strong
ooh this is not looking good okay you
can see for save the bishop now I'm
threatening rook t1 which he missed now
I'm winning a piece topsy-turvy I'm
keeping my streak I have a nine-point
Street or nine game streak about to be
ten games I just have to convert this
maybe not still not so simple let's play
this move and remember be two
threatening both III and a two step
taste a two is defended Bishop c5 I
guess okay he forgot his rook was
attacked this is just game over okay
next game no time to waste
streak of ten life is better I'm in
sixth place let's play of London okay we
have the same line did I play this guy
already maybe not oh this is my pet line
this is my pet line I gave a lecture on
this oh maybe he knows what he's doing
I showed this in the st. Louis Chess
Club YouTube video the Grand Prix I
don't know if I showed this line but I
think I did f6 I've never seen before I
just take on a 6 taking on a 6 take
bishop there maybe just 93 good position
okay I'm happy with this cuz he's played
off six whoa wow what was that like it
was glued to my mouse okay Bishop each
I'm just gonna play quickly hopefully
next few moves just Castle and complete
development you might play f5 at some
point let's play a 3 mm also play b6
he's also attacking the pawn decent move
let's play this so b4 doesn't quite work
this is actually not the most impressive
position maybe this move threatening c4
but maybe the position is about to be
impressive play C for covering the a 4
square and then back to c3 and then
preparing be for this Mike's almost
trapped just go to a 6 then Queen b3 ok
now I'd like the position place some
quick moves Knight c7 what to do - Queen
B - attacking up 6 IG for Oates continue
attacking f6 is pinned by the way ie 8
or the funny move what to do mates 5
have to retreat
let's build a pressure on the D file ooh
I hung the c4 pawn didn't even see it
Bishop h6 might be annoying at some
point
yeah let's retreat no idea what's going
on here I just gotta play quick
he seems like a quick player being
efficient like this time he's attacking
the Queen
let's move the Queen now g5 is a whole
hmm what's going on
I see pawns pin let's take once and then
plane that h3 this King should be unsafe
when the center opens up now there's a
pin on the D file I have a queen h6
ideas - this is looking better
it's just a confusing position 9.4 maybe
oh now therefore I'm not attacking the
Queen I'm also threatening Bishop to g7
Queen Day g6 this should be over take
and queen take g6 maybe it still takes
work no this is just over it because 96
that's nice winning the Queen your
resigns streak of 11 games I'm in fourth
place what what are the money prizes is
there money prizes for top three or top
five if anyone has an answer to that
that would be good to know or maybe it's
the top three streamers I forgot how it
works I'm playing an 1800 this is nice
the streak of the loving games I was on
tilt earlier but now I'm just trying to
play decent chess Bishop c4 I guess is a
move play 97 going for d5 and I'll
develop the Bishop to g7
maybe night before at some point just
get the bishop hair I play these
physicians more often from the white
side but this is pleasant Eric is now
Eric's titled rather than tilted I mean
you could be both I guess
but so I'm more titled than tilted now
maybe this move wait a minute what to do
Queen b6 is interesting it's like Queen
b6 you can't play Bishop III because
this I'm just building up pressure
although I don't know if there's any
immediate threat so there's so much
pressure on him c4 I take b3 or d3 slave
rook to AIDS so I don't see anything
media I'll just continue to improve c4
could be a major threat so Knight f4 I
he does yeah why not d5 defended I'm
preventing him from playing Queen h4 I'm
just trying to like squeeze him or Keats
or do I take rookie aids because all my
pieces are good all my pieces of ply
pressure in some way now I can win a
pawn if I want requires getting up the
bishop let's win the pond
you can't play h3 because Knight g3 you
might play this back for mmm there's
before and then h3 nice 9 a4
what to do what to do here Queenie to
maybe it's like we need to try and keep
some initiative if he takes my rooks my
one rook gets active it doesn't take a
second Queen take f2 so he plays that
move but his Queens tied down
where are the tactics I takes you to I
don't know c4 maybe c4 looks simple Oh
c4 is defended oops
but then rookie for okay that was kind
of accidental but yes it works out now
just made in one okay no time to waste
I'm playing Amon Hamilton what does he
play or replace French let's play c4 d
fide okay he's doing great stuff I could
transpose into a car oh let's transpose
into a car oh I'm going to stay an
opening theory
ah he's playing this sign let's play
this and then 92 and I hold onto the
pawn in some cases a 4 9 F 4 and then
like Bishop b3 he plays Knight b6 this
is OK oh he plays g5 g 5 is a decent
move I have 9 h5 though maybe maybe g5
nodded he said no no he'll probably wind
up a pawn but he's weakening his King
side well at least I'm playing I'm on
now and nots like earlier when I was
just so tilted but I still have to stay
focused
Lucy's thinking
last time I played online he was
streaming and he got mad at me because I
beat him three in a row and I stopped
playing him but okay I can take on g7 d4
may be our queen age 594 he's gonna play
h6 then it's some position maybe I'll
fly Queenie - do I have a 5 - at some
point take take a 5 looks nice because
he has to take and then I've c4 and d5
if I want is not a for coming maybe
maybe I do this first and then
eventually see four times about equal
but ok the position is gonna open up
like my bishops are gonna be here in
here and then there's could be diagonals
happening don't usually have enough time
to draw arrows I'm c4 looks like a major
threat what is he doing maybe this move
he wants to play Bishop g4 oh well allow
him cuz now 95
I've Queen e5 and he would have to
retreat in the meantime I just want to
play C 45 or h3 even he might do
something like this in this and cocoon
but rookie one I have tempo moves and I
have a time advantage
maybe half for coming a4 is just another
resource which it kind of looks good
and rookie one maybe I can provoke be
six I don't know though high provoke e6
let's just play c4 the Queen e6 aha
interesting Taiki Queens on the board
Queenie five weights or h3 I shouldn't
be thinking here but there's so many
good options and the key Queens on the
board Queen d2 looks passive but I just
want to play rook e1 with tempo he
really wants to trade okay we can trade
looks like when you seven I think he
missed that I didn't realize that at
first either but u7 is an important pod
he wants to win that let's do this
defend give you Ricky three at some
point and I'm d5 maybe f3 2 or h3 can
play up three solid let's move
want to avoid a time scramble maybe I
shouldn't have traded bishops that was
bad I'm still better though King f2
activates
king power important concept in chess
and centralized bishop is nice
those be plans week maybe I double up
maybe just see five and push him
yeah let's push him his rook strats ooh
I forgot you can't move okay seven this
is just about winning
mm-hmm oh no I forgot about the fork I'm
still winning though maybe I just have
to flagon doesn't have much time what
oh my gosh chefs calm free-moving
no that was so unfortunate I'm just not
used to time scrambles mmm
no the Prix moving was like terrible I
don't know if that was my fault or I was
I don't know okay
I know wasting time Austin homie on so
it's it's like played such a good game
it's just time scramble and then I
hovered over in the the thing like
blocked the board ouch
okay well I'm playing some guy number
six so half hour left Bishop f4 would
have been a bad move to pre moved there
I have to remember the sign now I think
Bishop here
listen Knight c3 and like rook be 195
there's some refutation I think this is
it Queen here oh that was so unfortunate
p4 okay rip d1
[Music]
age six what to do should be five maybe
even Queen f4 looks interesting I'm
gonna play Bishop e2 wait I have so many
options let's play Bishop e5 just
curious if I'm threatening to take
because I might be like a six take take
night before Queen e6 and I have an ID
for so I'm threatening to take on c6 you
can't take here it goes Forks so sad now
okay what to do
f3 I guess now I just want to play this
move of course he can't take this Queen
d8 mates ooh a five I forgot about a
five what to do am i worse might be
worse here
25 on Quincy 3 check ok 1 Navy that
doesn't work either
ok I used so much time I can't like if
you get below like 10 seconds it's
pretty much a death sentence so I'm just
gonna play down the piece and can you
still castle legally
okay you can't castle now because I take
on e7 now he might Castle
maybe there's Trixie if he castles I
have Knight f6 okay you figure out about
nice you seven that's nice mmm what to
do my Knights trapped but I can't think
I just have to move well let's do this
maybe I can trap this Queen
now he's gonna play a four
this is gonna be funny a three rippy 3 a
2 rupee - or not cleans my trapped but
my rooks indeed ok I have to resort to
flagging him let's do this some point I
want to play like g3 or h3 - problem g3
ok probability h3 okay interesting
let's do this threatening Queen b6
[Music]
okay well now I have a time advantage so
that's nice let's not play Queenie one I
hope you should take HV that's kind of
scary
wait a minute wait I have to move much
quicker wow there's so much lag this is
really annoying oh my gosh
I don't know if I'm lagging earthís
sites lagging like everything just seems
so slow I I mean I have to take the
blame for losing that game because like
I hung the knight earlier to learn my
lesson not to get into these time
scrambles oh it's so sad so much tilt
now it's like I started with tilts I got
this tree you can now back on the losing
streak mmm
what am i doing what are the standings
I'm still in top ten I'm gonna play this
line d5 is a playable move sometimes
especially if White's not familiar with
the line
sleep assured g4 prevent him from
castling though it could get very crazy
very quickly if he plays a3 those where
does my knight go f3 f3 is a pleasant
surprise
because as Bishop is bad if these ideas
okay now it's just a positional gain uh
you couldn't play quickly to not
hopefully not get below a minute in this
game can I take here that went up on
take take take yeah this is just waiting
upon no need to worry let's play c6 okay
this is just a technical position your
play tonight g4 or maybe snag upon in
each two could also just trade a bunch
of things
happy to trade night for Bishop as
bishops awkward I'll play Bishop f3
probably there should be one its invade
so play g6 Calvin another pawn I'll get
a slightly active rook or maybe I
prevent him king f7 and King f7 why not
relatively technical work ending
maybe I'll go for some mating attack
like g5g for he has to play G for
himself I think and then ask for oh
maybe not weights this is just mates
does king g 6h three rock h2
so I guess it really helps if I get a
streak I have a streak of one in 8th
place I'm ahead of Amon who's in 10th
place ok let's play e4 in this game
oh just try and win as many games as
quickly as possible
I'll play an alkyne I don't really study
this line too much but I know the setup
like Bishop b2 and Knight b BD - that's
a decent line how to continue rook e1
maybe this pawns always defended what
did you cook c1
it's a positional line not exactly the
line I was hoping for but it's something
yeah if I didn't lose a games I think I
would have gotten more points because of
the streak and those were such
disappointing games I was better in both
of the house well that's just the nature
of blitz and time scrambles I play this
move I guess I can play this move this
game space b5 or c5 maybe h3 first I
can't play that go for b5 where is is
Mike going you seven maybe and I'll go
for like night
I still can't play tonight have fun
maybe my bishops just misplaced go for
this over defending the pawn and then
going for that etholon I just want to
play like night off one night g3 whoo
there's pressure like III I guess
see five ideas maybe though maybe not
thanks for the follow and my pub what to
do g4 g5 does that win material you only
live once I think is bishops now trapped
I mean you can take h3 maybe you got
some comp but I'm happy to win a bishop
I mean he will have cop here like this
is actually slightly scary do I have
night chief
for g5 these no checks and this is just
a fork where is this Queen going Queen
h4 I just take now I'm up a full rook
you still has some attack by defend
they cheat too I guess
now there's a pin as bishops attack
twice isn't his queen is attacked once
this Queen has nowhere to go to the
feminine dishes so this was just winning
okay maybe I'll get in like I don't know
to read more games hopefully three to
four more games
maybe I'll break 2,400 again I still
don't understand how this point system
works let's play another efore game
Sicilian this one to play against ax
village you're asking for a scotch but
it's hard to play the Scotch when they
play the Sicilian if you want to see a
scotch look at look at Nakamura against
Robson it's kind of a crazy crazy
opening at least last time I looked okay
now we have a typical like g3 versus
time on earth a lot of the moves are
like easy to play for a white like
Bishop III g4f for maybe eventually a5
in Bishop e6 that's from an 85 you might
play b6 but I'm okay with that
mmm do I play Bishop e3 or take probably
take because it comes with tempo and
then like start pawn storming
let's play up for preventing any like
9594 sometimes is annoying
okay 97 g5 continually gaining space I
could take I can't retreat
it's retreats I just want to keep
pushing
oh he's attacking see - mmm what to do
let's do this
thanks for the bits downward is
heavenward chess is complicated and
painful maybe play a carro con if I'm
black next game my opponent plays e4
I'll play a Carroll Khan just for you
but remind me because I'll probably
forget d5 scary take take the center is
opening up just have to play quickly 54
have to take more be two's hanging not
what I wanted now the my pawns are just
overextended Kings side is weak but it
should still be playable
I really have to pay attention to time
c4 maybe coming my blocks under pressure
now especially against this Knight and
the Queen and the bishop and his time
queen c3 interesting
I just want to play rope d3 so I'm in
10th place the time is ticking for the
tournament they're 17 minutes left wrote
III why not make his Queen move
but with his knight and his Queen our
attacks maybe Queen before Oh Mina and
then erupted II for the white should be
winning something
tick tick okay and he's flagging
okay interesting game I have a streak of
three I'm in eighth place with 50
something points this should be a
winnable tournament it would have been a
winnable tournament if I didn't mess up
I'm playing a 1487 okay let's smash this
guy quickly I'll play not use more than
one minute off my clock oh my gosh I
almost Mouse slipped b6 there I'll play
a marshal if he lets me c3 so early I
just take the pawn on e4 maybe I
actually don't know theory here I just
know this guy's rating I should beat him
quickly let's play Bishop g4 yeah Bishop
g4 is a useful move when they play d4
and no HD because now I just run a pawn
unless he wants to take with the Jeep on
this is nice
be c5 next let's bring the Knight to e5
you might play at 4 ok 95o
reinforcing Knights maybe hope Odell you
have 92 I've had 92 maybe you'll still
miss it talking too quickly there okay
92 that's nice please resign yes okay
streak of 460 points 7 place first place
has 70 points playing home lights
let's play another Evora game or a 5
game um
this is my opening to try and win
quickly okay he's flying this line would
Knight c3 I haven't played this in a
level over this line okay with d5 I mean
blacks just stop up on there's some
tricks to the sign like black has to
Castle before Bishop III is played but
it should be just better for black so
I'm I'm in sixth place 13 minutes left
also we have time for two more games
after this game let's play Bishop g6o
Bishop g6 loses the pawn I forgot about
that should have played rookie AIDS okay
well now I can take this is nice
maybe ninety seven only issue at this
position it could take a while to win
just because a symmetrical nature c6
solid and he has the e-file so I have to
play like Queen d7 and rookie Yates will
trade down you might play h4 I forgot to
play a Carroll Khan I'm sorry you didn't
remind me or did you remind me I wasn't
looking at the chat I'm sorry but
there's money on the line I have to play
or that I'm most comfortable with just
to win the quickest okay let's take and
then trade rooks and then the Queen
Knight combination is usually just
better than the Queen Bishop combination
especially when I have an extra pawn
I'll probably play h3 here or that move
I have this
let's play this attack what's he doing I
have four maybe you can't think the
night cuz Queenie one mates now I want
to play Queen d1 or we go into this
where I have 92 in the end there 92 just
next move
threatening Queen G 1 wait he has Queen
B a check but it's just one check oh
here's that move okay it's not quite
over
maybe this move threatening 93 yeah so
play Bishop d6 it's still not over
g5 I guess I'm playing overly
aggressively okay let's see if he takes
up on cuz Knight g3 is just oh and I g3
is not smashing where's my win I win
should be somewhere I'll play Queen c1
defend the g5 pawn from a distance
maybe I'll just flag him it's probably
the easiest way I got a bit too feisty
this is actually tricky I mean he's just
so stuck though do this stuff hold
everything together he's still stuck
king f7 coming next or not let's do this
d1 wait let's not repeat okay let's go
into this ending that's a race but I
mean he's got a flag at some point oh
there should be seven okay well I can
just win the bishop
okay Gigi
let's not stalemate him clean up three
would be a disaster okay next game
Sarika five I'm in seventh place only
seven place 64 points
so you'll well I'm playing Seville who's
probably watching the stream I think so
feels been a regular viewer in the past
c4 okay so we have a ver ver Sicilian
play treat it like in English like a six
and d6 let's play e4 interesting move
playing a bit more aggressively than
normal
hopefully it pays off h5 just have to
win as many games as possible next like
eight minutes
am i fighting Knight f3 I might be oh he
might be watching so I have to be
careful what I say too
this is already looking very very good
we should be three I mean if you want to
resign Seville just save yourself the
pain and the suffering its take oh wait
I'm just working the Queen I was
calculating Queen d2 and I take B - this
is just over that was nice okay next
game I'm in third place okay um I let's
keep the streak let's get at least one
more game and hopefully two games GG
Seville please start a next game
okay I'm playing X key nice this is what
I need some beatable opponent I can win
quickly and then maybe get one more game
in that's why I for an aggressive
playing most aggressive as possible play
Knight of 300 can i play you 5 yeah why
not
you five trying to play very very
aggressive and take two let's play 94
maybe go for a c4
maybe t6 will hang in the end if he
takes it doesn't take okay let's take
here and I'm v3 put the bishop on b2 and
go for some King side attack
yeah like night night f g5 and queen h5
coming this looks fun queen h5 I mean
I'm not really calculating HTG 5 I think
I'm threatening that of six so I have
six could be a beautiful finish please
allow 906 I'm just gonna take his time
here movie blocks take take I don't see
the win you can just take here though
wait did I mess this up take-take-take
please don't tell me I mess this up
we're just trading though let's take
care yeah we're just trading but it's
going to take a bit longer to win this
at least I'm winning c5 this is
completely winning position I was hoping
to just end it with the attack but we'll
just end it with the endgame up two
pawns are up one pawn I don't want to be
that ambitious
oh let's do this mmm he's running two
things forget three defense both of them
it's a little bit annoying let's play
King after I want to play g4 not worry
about night h4 and then I want to play
96 96 we can trade a bunch of things
that's fine and these these multiple pre
moves are just freaky but I guess it's
convenient Bishop back h4 as night has
almost no squares yeah let's play h4 I
doubt I'll have time for one working ooh
I forgot about that move luckily a half
Keaney 4 and so we didn't King pawn
ending also flagging him
let's make a passer on the Queen side oh
did I want to do that I guess is still
okay
this is just winning okay next game well
I have time for one more game I'm in
fourth place No
so people pass me I need to I guess I
need to beat people to continue or to
what am I trying to say I need to win
one more game to fight for top three oh
I'm playing the best opponent I can play
okay I have to I have to play as
aggressively as possible and pre move
stuff okay he's already blundering
that's nice
it's very nice go for this e5 break as
soon as possible maybe castle first
maybe t3 first actually and then likeif
I've just Russell upon you can take on
f3 if he wants he's six I guess just
about meeting him I would like to win
this game quickly where is a mate's
Queen there there there it seems very
very close maybe you'll play 94 next and
confuse him his Knights tied down and
threatening made into mmm let's take
like this and then threatening me five
oh no I'm not turning if I have to
castle first this is what happens when I
try to learn quickly it's a bit messy
we've 40 seconds until the game ends
you'd better not use all this time
please resigning knight of seven maybe
if I win this Queen he'll resign please
resign please resign please resign come
on
here's one legal move come on oh this is
so frustrating
oh it's so frustrating
he's not gonna resign I'm the finish in
fourth place because the tournament's
gonna end
that's annoying well I
I finished in fourth place if I won that
game I don't know how many points I with
a score like I still don't know what the
scoring system is I was on some kind of
streak but fourth place not bad slow
start very very
freaky finish I have to go cuz I have a
bus to catch in one hour I'm going to LA
tonight and I don't want to miss the bus
I'm ending the stream here thanks guys
for watching and I will be back maybe
tonight if not tonight maybe later in
the week bye